[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
May 8th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
most Americans don't have a will and
upon their death that could put the
future of their belongings and assets at
risk and result in devastating
consequences for their heirs Wall Street
Journal personal finance reporter Ashley
Ebling is here so first of all Ash layup
what is a will and what is its purpose
well I can't overemphasize the
importance of having a will it's a
catch-all document it determines who
gets your stuff but would also determine
who would be the guardian of minor
children and who basically handles
everything at your death that would be
called an Executor if you have a will or
administrator if you end up not having a
will what kinds of assets does a will
typically cover everything basically
your house your bank accounts all your
belongings your car
it won't cover retirement accounts and
life insurance policies those passed by
way of beneficiary designations so it's
really important that you coordinate all
your estate planning in one place so
what happens if someone dies and doesn't
have a will filled out a range of state
laws would dictate who gets your assets
your loved ones could get nothing they
might get kicked out of the family house
they could face Hefty surprise tax bills
it could really be a mess and yet in
your reporting you cite data that says
not only that the wealth of American
households has tripled over the past 30
years but also that more than half of
Americans in 2021 said they didn't have
a will given the fact that all these
terrible things could happen why don't
they have a will well it's not just lack
of awareness it's just really really
tough Schwab did a recent survey that
showed for people with a million plus
and investable assets one out of five of
them even don't have Wills so it's at
all income ranges and asset levels it's
a tough decision especially complex if
they're complex family Dynamics at stake
there's a really interesting chart in
your Wall Street Journal story which
shows how this issue of having a will
and not having a will sort of runs along
demographic lines what does it tell us
so that tells us that among non-white
adults it's a bigger problem there's 72
percent of non-white adults who say they
don't have a will compared to 45 percent
of white adults
I guess some good news is as people age
they tend to get their estate planning
documents together you know in the 18 to
29 year old range they're 80 percent of
those people don't have Wills but by the
time people get 65 plus then it's one
out of four people don't have one part
of it is people are just afraid of doing
something that they think is going to be
so set in stone so one nudge that can
help people to get a will done is to
focus on what feels right for the next
three to five years knowing a will can
and should be updated as life happens
think of it as a work in progress one
estate planner told me what's the cost
by the way of drawing up a will that
could range from a few hundred dollars
to a few thousand dollars it really
depends on the complexity and the wealth
and what steps do people take to fill
one out generally you would go to your
local estate planner in your state and
that's because state laws vary greatly
there are online wills and you can
literally right one yourself but they're
very specific State rules as to whether
or not a will is going to be valid if
it's signed and dated whether they're
Witnesses so you have to make sure
you're abiding by all those rules what
was really remarkable in your story is
how the rules in different states are
starkly different and so there is not
one magic formula for how your assets
would be allocated based upon what you
have in your will so that's the huge
surprise right A lot of people who were
married would think their surviving
spouse would get a hundred percent of
their assets and that is the case in
some states but then in other states the
percentage split varies Tennessee for
example there's a surviving spouse with
two or more children the surviving
spouse would get a third of the estate
and the rest would be split equally
among the children and that can have
this devastating consequence of a
surviving spouse actually left without
enough to keep up the house and the way
they have been used to living you spoke
to a gentleman in Washington state whose
live-in partner did not have a will when
she died how did that affect him so
that's an example of how the state laws
absolutely do nothing for live-in
partners
basically disinheriting them she died in
a horseback riding accident the week
before they had an appointment actually
to draw up Wills and while he was
grieving he had to get her sons who live
in England to sign off so he could be
appointed by the local probate court to
administer the estate and he said that
she wanted him to have the six hundred
thousand dollar house and their car a
Volkswagen SUV that they'd bought all
those things together but by law her
sons were entitled to her 50 interest
basically to keep his house in his car
he had to buy out the sons and he said
it was quite a struggle she died just
days before they were going to go check
out a will and that's the tragedy people
need to get these done and sooner rather
than later the fact that she was a
live-in partner and they weren't married
how did that affect this process there
are no states that automatically leave
assets to live-in Partners there's some
that have something called a committed
relationship statue that if you can
prove you're in a committed relationship
then you would get part of the estate
and then not to make things too
complicated but they're nine states that
have community property laws including
Washington state where this couple lived
and in those States there's the 50 50
split of property that you've earned or
bought together there are a lot of
details to this process and so how can
people do research to give them a better
picture of how their State's laws govern
wills and their assets but also what
might happen to their belongings if they
die without a will so one website I'd
actually send people to is called Air
Base
h-e-i-r-b-a-s-e airbase.com a
Pennsylvania lawyer basically is doing
this as a hobby he's developed these
online intestacy calculators or
evaluators that you can enter your
family information and see what might
happen if you die without a will and
they're for every state
on a local Probate Court they have
information about your state laws too
and obviously going to an estate planner
and for the volunteer income tax
assistance centers for the elderly they
have estate planning meetings for people
too and while a will can help protect
your physical belongings what about your
emails photos and online accounts they
live on even after you die so how can
you protect your digital footprint
before that happens check out the April
28th episode of our sister podcast Tech
news briefing the Metro money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]